[Música]
[Aplausos]
é fácil
é muito fácil a gente publicamente
receber títulos
se eleito o perfil número um a ser
seguido
se eleito o profissional do anos eleito
o melhor profissional de rh é muito
fácil muito fácil a gente mostrar para o
público aquilo que a gente quer formar
de opinião no público difícil a gente
pratica dentro da nossa casa
aquilo que a gente prega publicamente a
minha avó tem 93 anos está sentado aqui
hoje a senhora baixinha ele
ela fez aniversário quinta feira passada
[Música]
e eu não liguei pra ela mas eu lembrei
de ligar para os amigos públicos
eu lembrei de fazer um networking no
linkedin
eu lembrei de mandar um e mail eu
lembrei de dar os parabéns mas eu não
lembrei de ligar pra minha avó não
adianta você ter sucesso na vida pública
se você não leva consigo essa mensagem
para dentro da sua casa antes de
completar 18 anos de idade eu já tinha
um transtorno
algumas pessoas que convivem comigo
sabem do que se trata
eu tinha 18 anos e era gago tem algum
gago aqui na platéia
ninguém né como quase não têm negros
eu passei minha infância inteira sendo
um gago
eu passei muitos anos fazendo terapia
para superar a gagueira eu comecei a ser
gago porque eu queria imitar um amigo da
escola que era muito gago e esse amigo
sofreu bullying eu te confesso que eu
não sei se eu comecei a imitá lo para
fazer bullying ou pra fazer parte
daquele social com ele eu não fui gago
por imitação eu fui gago porque eu tinha
um outro distúrbio
esse distúrbio é pela primeira vez a
minha mãe também está na platéia minha
esposa na platéia meu sócio na platéia
pela primeira vez eu compartilho público
eu sofri um distúrbio chamado transtorno
de ansiedade generalizada
eu tenho uma ansiedade tão aguda que eu
sequer consegui dormir ontem eu acho que
três dias sem dormir pra fazer essa
palestra aqui de 18 minutos
toda vez que eu faço uma palestra e
falou que vai ser a última porque eu
fico absolutamente gastado eu falei que
sim
a última é essa aqui ontem me convidaram
pra mim o kaká tudo mas acatou do rio de
janeiro no museu das artes sexta feira
agora eu aceitei como um bom gago eu
preciso de alguns suportes
então eu trouxe algumas anotações aqui
no monitor da frente só vai me dar um
pouco mais de segurança
semana passada eu tive no exterior eu
fui estados unidos o furacão com pelo
poder no networking
chegando lá eu não conseguia concluir
uma única frase em inglês
eu morei nos estados unidos eu estudei
no estado eu trabalhei nos estados
unidos e não conseguia completar uma
única frase você sabe o que é você ser
convidado tudo de graça
o tão simples cinco estrelas e chegar à
recepção você não consegue perguntar se
o café da manhã estava incluído
e ainda você olha no cardápio 35 dólares
por pessoa
eu fiquei seis dias fazendo a conta para
saber quanto é que custava ao café
[Risadas]
aí quando fui pagar a conta era zero
puxa que alívio mas eu fiquei com aquela
ansiedade né
gago ansioso nossa olha tem de ser gago
está aqui neste palco os refletores
acesos meu rosto
a câmera me filmando agora transmitida
ao vivo pelo facebook tem de ser gago e
falar em público é aterrorizante e é
mais aterrorizante falar em público com
a presença da sua voz da sua mãe da sua
esposa do seu sócio dos seus sócios que
estão aqui hoje eu estou absolutamente
aterrorizado eu quero pedir uma
gentileza para vocês verdade
se em algum momento gaguejado essa
palestra a pauta porque eu fico
confortável e ajuda a edição do liquida
depois do vídeo né
parece que foi muito aplaudido se eu
chegar até o final sem água já a prova
também porque você mais confiante do que
eu cheguei aqui hoje e só hoje sou eu
aqui de caos para me conectar com vocês
para me conectar com esse espírito
que existe nessa sala o espírito de
crescimento de união de aprendizado é de
amor eu estou aqui hoje estou aqui hoje
quase como uma redenção por ter passado
grande parte da minha vida sem a atenção
para a minha mãe para minha avó e mesmo
quando morava muito próximo da minha mãe
da minha avó
eu quase nunca é na casa delas eu
procurava um amigo eu procurava o
network público esquecia de praticar
network dentro da minha própria casa
[Aplausos]
eu não cheguei ainda
[Música]
todos vocês sabem que a comunicação é
essencial para um bom networking alguém
duvida disso
se você não consegue se comunicar você
não consegue fazer networking imagina um
gago numa roda de conversa tentando se
expressar tentando colocar sua opinião é
doido isso né
as pessoas dizem que os gagos não tem
nada para dizer à opinião dos gagos não
importa
hoje vocês estão assistindo um gago para
mostrar que a opinião de um gago importa
e mais do que isso que o gago que sofre
de ansiedade pode se construir um dos
maiores networking do brasil esse gago
construiu esse network todos vocês aqui
conseguem fazer mesmo quando tinha 16
anos e estava concluindo o ensino médio
técnico e precisa fazer um estágio
naquela época não conhecia ninguém que
eu fiz eu fui consultar maior
especialista em networking do mundo que
é a minha mãe mas precisa de um estádio
para concluir pegar o diploma ela deu
medo de telefonemas conseguiu estágio
pra mim no instituto militar de
engenharia
caramba em que deu tudo errado eu não
queria trabalhar eu só queria o estádio
pra concluir o curso chega às 7 horas da
manhã e eu sou um suburbano da ilha do
governador
e ela pra o fusca 7 horas da manhã
chegando ao descobrir que não é nada que
eu ia trabalhar pra aprender
putz fiquei seis meses nessa loucura
todo dia e voltando e voltando
acabou o estágio na alemanha agora dá
pra arranjar um estágio que eu ganho
dinheiro ela ligou para alguns amigos e
conseguiu um estágio pra ganhar dinheiro
cheguei no dia na agência de turismo
face por isso vou arrebentar sou cara da
internet da ati e da informática
ai meu chefe me chamou de vitamina a que
é arrumar ali então ali e 25 mil fichas
de clientes a gente resolveu
informatizar nossa agência o seu
trabalho é digitar todas elas no
computador que você vai ganhar 20
centavos por cada ficha e eu catando
milho né
seis meses oito meses depois não lembro
me formei datilografia e foi demitido
porque as fichas acabaram faz bom vou de
novo a seu nome e networking para
conseguir emprego né
vou falar com a minha mãe na verdade tá
maluco militar e ficha
claro que não procurei um amigo esse meu
amigo conseguiu emprego pra mim um
provedor de internet
trabalhei em 97 vinte anos depois o meu
chefe daquele provedor hoje o diretor de
uma grande empresa multinacional que é a
maior empresa que é o maior cliente da
empresa atualmente
será que nesses 20 anos foi só uma
coincidência ou será que de alguma
maneira eu estava praticando o
networking sem saber
muita gente fala que o que é uma coisa
nociva qi quem indica
quando a gente queria criticar um colega
de trabalho que a gente falava fulano de
tal trabalho aqui porque ele tem que ir
alguém já ouviu isso alguma vez na vida
eu já ouvi várias vezes fulano tem que
ir lá não é competente fão tem que ir o
que ia tomar nuance do network
a gente nunca foi treinado para praticar
networking
mas a gente praticava mesmo sem saber o
que é isso é o networking praticados em
gente saber
fez esse diretor contratar uma empresa
atualmente
foi o que fez os amigos da minha mãe me
contratarem lá atrás ela de confiança
quando eu confio em você e você confia
nela eu posso confiar nela a confiança
transitiva e através do network você
começa a criar uma rede gigantesca de
confiança com transitividade eu confio
na câmera ela confie em você eu confio
em você você confia nela eu confio nela
e assim a gente vai criando a nossa rede
de relacionamento
estou passando aqui errado acho que vou
começar a viajar daqui a pouco
muitas empresas procuram contratar pelo
network é por indicação tem empresas que
pagam o dinheiro dos seus funcionários
que indicam profissionais para serem
contratados porque elas fazem isso
porque isso reduz risco na medida que
você contrata alguém que é indicado por
alguém que você confia
você reduz o seu risco de prejuízo
porque essa pessoa que foi contratada
ela deve agora de deveres
as duas pessoas o chefe e amigo de cor
ela não vai querer criar uma relação com
um amigo e parecia que o amigo não sabe
indicar boas pessoas
então ela passa a prestar conta para
duas pessoas por isso que as empresas
hoje em dia buscam muita gente através
do networking é um consenso hoje
entregar no mundo que 80% das vagas de
emprego não são anunciadas sabiam disso
essas vagas estão disponíveis somente
pelo networking
eu não sei se é verdade mas na minha
empresa por exemplo 100% das pessoas que
eu contratei vieram pelo networking
eu não tenho nenhuma pessoa que eu
contratei colocando vaga por exemplo na
internet
muita gente acha que o networking é um
processo que tem início meio e fim
networking não é isso a network1 estado
de espírito é uma maneira de pensar
é uma maneira de se relacionar com o
outro muita gente faz
work pensando somente no lado
profissional e se esquece que o
networking é para todas as esferas da
sua vida
há mais ou menos quatro meses o meu
filho de 4 anos rafael sofreu um
acidente muito grave
quem me acompanha no link deve ter visto
tem alguém que já acompanha aqui no link
dinho bom
algumas pessoas ele estava com a mão na
porta um amiguinho bateu a mão e quase
decepou o dedo dele ele foi pro hospital
ter que fazer cirurgia de emergência
trinta minutos a chegar no hospital de
maiores cirurgiões plásticos do brasil
me ligou oferecendo a rede de
relacionamento dele como ajuda não pedia
ele simplesmente se ofereceu para ajudar
o meu filho foi operado pelo melhor
cirurgião de mão do país
tudo bem ele estava de plantão no
hospital não foi network foi
coincidência será será que existe
coincidência nessa vida
ou será que o universo conspira a favor
daqueles que se propõem a fazer o bem
meu filho não tem sequela nenhuma
e talvez esse poder da reciprocidade que
a gente consegue através do network que
faz com que essa roda gire que faz com
que a gente se sustente a nossa vida em
sociedade e sustentar nossas relações
sociais à medida que você ajuda alguém
esse alguém ele fica absolutamente
compelido e devolver essa ajuda
e essa ajuda muitas vezes volta em dobro
imagino network como sendo orquídeas que
você coloca um tronco de uma árvore
pouco e seca em algum momento essa
árvore vai te vai ficar maior que já vai
cair
o network para ser feito com propriedade
ele precisa ter conteúdo e o conteúdo
são suas habilidades habilidades essas
que são impossíveis de serem expressos
no currículo
eu contratei uma ano passado contratou
mais testes
txt e esteticista sexista esportista
caramba eu tenho uma empresa de rh para
que eu vou contratar uma esteticista
porque ela tinha as habilidades que eu
precisava eu só soube dessas habilidades
por conta da rede de relacionamento ela
foi uma indicação inclusive ela casou
com essa indicação sábado
[Risadas]
e essa indicação é um funcionário eu
trabalha comigo há oito anos então é
mais do que uma indicação com segurança
o trabalho agora juntos se essa minha
nova funcionária fosse colocar suas
habilidades no currículo as pessoas em
tentariam se tratar de elogios ao
tecnologias né
ah eu sou comprometida eu respeito o
horário eu sei lidar com dinheiro sujo
se coloca no currículo como você
consegue conhecer essas competências só
existe uma maneira através do networking
network tem como produto final criar
laços duradouros vida para que você
possa construir sua carreira não só
profissional mas construir sua carreira
de vida tendo pessoas que te ajudem
eu lembro que eu nunca fui muito bem
física mas eu sempre acreditei que o
networking que o que eu conquistasse
fosse é termos de trabalho fosse um
produto temático
quanto mais esforço multiplicado pelo
tempo eu teria resultado eu descobri que
não é isso que o sucesso vem através da
física se lembra daquela história da
alavanca
não é que você consegue movimentar
pedras pesadas fazendo alavanca o
network é alavanca é a alavanca que
destrava sua vida como destravou a minha
porque você vai ter mais esforço se você
pode trabalhar e gerar resultados com
menos esforço e com muito menos tempo
o network tem a força de levar você rumo
ao seu objetivo profissional ao seu
objetivo pessoal ao seu objetivo de
carreira com muito mais facilidade
ele tem a força de colocar você em
contato com
quer pessoa que você queira na sua vida
sem sombra de dúvida o networking abre
portas para fazer network você precisa
ter conteúdo para fazer networking
você precisa saber influenciar pessoas
ea bíblia sobre network foi escrita em
1932 um livro chamado como fazer amigos
e influenciar pessoas que não leu esse
livro ainda
leia e olha eu acredito na verdade tenho
certeza meu sócio da que ele fala que eu
tenho muita certeza na vida e terapeuta
falar a mesma coisa eu sou cheio de
certezas tem um tem um rei dentro de
mexer com certeza eu prometo que eu tô
trabalhando com isso eu acredito que o
networking não é a competência do futuro
ele a competência do presente
ele é competência que faz você ter
sucesso em qualquer aspecto da sua vida
pessoal profissional de negócios até
mesmo para encontrar é uma noiva como
aconteceu com meu funcionário foi
network network destrava a sua vida o
networking destravou a minha vida
será que é difícil fazer network vocês
consideram de ser difícil fazer
networking
olha se você está aqui hoje vocês
fizeram network talvez de maneira
inconsciente mas fizeram agora imagina o
poder de alcance que vocês terão se
vocês conseguirem fazer networking de
maneira proposital de maneira
estratégica de maneira consciente
já imaginou o que vocês conseguiram
chegar eu cheguei nesse palco eu estou
nesse palco porque há dois anos eu
decidir fazer networking de maneira
estratégica com resultados com foco em
resultados com um objetivo muito claro
network é acima de tudo oferecer ajuda
ajudar o outro sem se preocupar com seus
próprios interesses
quando você ajuda o outro sem se
preocupar com seus próprios interesses
ajuda volta e ela volta x mil como
voltou pra mim e como pode também voltar
pra vocês
essa é a mensagem que eu acreditava que
vale a pena compartilhar
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]